à la réunion la presse locale parle
d'épidémie galopante face à la fièvre de
chikungunya ce virus transmis par les
moustiques connue en afrique et en asie
n'était encore jamais arrivé dans l'île
de l'océan indien où il se répand de
façon spectaculaire à la réunion pouvant
connaît ces hommes qui traquent
moustiques ses larmes
depuis une semaine ceux-ci sillonnent
les quartiers des camélias providence et
montgailhard ils ont même reçu le
renfort des équipes venues de l'ouest
car l'épidémie de chikungunya gagne du
terrain très très rapidement le premier
cas a été signalé le 14 avril à saint
pierre ce matin 150 personnes avaient
été recensés principalement à saint
denis pour se protéger east dentaires
les premiers symptômes sont apparus
samedi dernier situation
les doigts restent bloqués et puis une
sensation de
la fièvre fatigue douleurs bouton les
caractéristiques de la chikungunya
d'ailleurs ce monde d'origine swahili
signifie avoir les os cassés dans cette
pharmacie quatre des six employés sont
atteints et il voit arriver de plus en
plus de malades
quelqu'un comme ça mais c'est vraiment
fonctionnel et là aujourd'hui
cinq personnes ici on suit attentivement
la progression de la chikungunya dans
les trois ou quatre semaines à venir
on s'attend à une flambée du nombre des
cas